as we've been hearing the un refugee
agency says the number of people fleeing
ukraine has now passed the one million
mark making it the fastest exodus of
refugees so far this century most are
heading towards poland with other
neighboring countries like romania also
taking refugees
but some are having to wait longer than
others to cross to safety as dw
correspondent fannie farchar observed
on the border
finally here thousands are pouring
towards the ukrainian border with
romania as word spreads of the tailback
of refugees at the polish crossing
with harrowing images still in their
minds and few items in their hands
they arrive at the last checkpoint to
safety
oksana and her kids needed four days to
get here from keith on her mind what's
ahead
we are going to look for work because i
need to provide for my children and my
husband stayed to defend his country
men of fighting age between 18 and 60
have to stay
there are also many non-ukrainians who
want to leave students migrant workers
about half a million according to u.n
estimates
hundreds of thousands of people are
fleeing for their lives heading west for
the border now all these people from
across ukraine are running from the same
thing but are they all getting the same
treatment
ahmed fled from heavily bombed kharkiv a
student from egypt he says he's growing
frustrated about being made to wait in
freezing temperatures while ukrainians
are let through
they they let us only pass after like
out hundreds of killings we will pass i
can't say anything about this but still
you're humans also
like they said us any they should
care more about us
ahmed says he has already been to live
but was not let through at the border
with poland there we are far away from
our countries it's the same situation
swore also on us
i don't think we should die for them to
live everyone should live
his friend also from egypt disagrees
i
feel about these people
they have no home to go and actually we
have home we have egypt we can go now
like you see but they
don't have any place to go
officials here do not want to talk on
camera about why there are two lines one
for foreigners one for ukrainians but
they tell us their goal is to maintain
calm here
there is concern that the situation
might get out of control as more
refugees take the alternative route to
romania we are not allowed to film ahmed
and his friend cross the border but
after a few hours they do just like
thousands of others finally to safety
a dw correspondent fanny fascia who
filed that report joins me now fanny
you're about 50 kilometers from the
border with romania and moldova
how is the situation where you are
people here in chattanooga which is yes
uh about 50 to 60 kilometers from the
border with romania are trying to gather
basically first of all all the
belongings and the energy to make it
through this next challenge to get
across the border the people who arrive
here in chernivtsi have been through a
lot already some of them have been
actually traveling for the past four
days to make it from kiev or from
kharkiv all the way here to the
southwestern part of ukraine so the next
challenge to them trying to make it
across the border and as we have seen in
that report but also yesterday being at
the border with romania there are a lot
of people who are now trying to look for
alternative routes as we know at the
beginning of this full-scale invasion
that started last week in fact just a
week ago on thursday a lot of people
were pouring towards the western border
with poland but now as more and more
people are trying to make it through
poland which is getting more and more
difficult by the day they're also
looking for alternative routes be
through romania moldova hungary there is
a tense a calm tense at the border that
we have witnessed yesterday because you
have to imagine once you make it to the
border you really have been through a
lot uh regardless whether you are an
adult or a child and obviously being a
child you experience things on a
different level even more so but people
are just trying to get across the board
and bring their own life and that of
their families to safety
well you've obviously been speaking to
lots of people there trying to flee uh
we're hearing those harrowing stories
what kind of stories have been paid us a
picture if you will of what peop what
people's stories there
people who uh
we're coming from harkie for example
that one family uh the mother of uh with
four children she was basically telling
us if she didn't have any children she
probably would have stayed with her
husband now we hear that from a lot of
women who really are just uh
it's inconceivable actually for to all
of us but this means that you are trying
to save one part of your family well you
have to leave another part behind
because obviously if you're a man of
fighting age between 18 and 60 you have
to stay in ukraine uh you have to be
ready if you get that call to actually
join this fight and go to the front line
even a lot of men voluntarily have
already done so because they don't want
to give up any land they don't want to
give up the sovereignty of their country
also we see a lot of children at the
buddha crying they are
in
waiting there in freezing temperatures
with their mother and
you don't even want to know what the
eyes of these children have seen already
it's really a very heart-wrenching
situation even for us just observing it
and having to to film this obviously to
keep everyone informed let alone what uh
what about the mental stage about the
mental state of these people who have
been through this uh some really i
needed not just four days to arrive from
kharkiv to uh the romanian border but
actually there were also people who
tried to make it across the polish
border so they were already in lev which
is the major town before crossing uh to
poland they didn't get through so they
came to to this part of the country
a lot of a lot of extra exhaustion there
that we could see but also a lot of fear
and concern in the eyes of the people
standing in line trying to make it out
the art of this country
and funny where are most people headed
what have they been telling you do they
plan to stay in romania or those
bordering countries or do they want to
travel further into western europe
depends if you speak to foreigners
they're about half a million students
and migrant workers who are here in
ukraine and they are telling us they're
trying to actually make it home so home
could be anything from egypt nigeria if
they actually get the support from the
government because obviously it's very
difficult right now to navigate anyone
out of this country and to safety but
most people i've been speaking to are
just happy to make it across the border
be in romania be in bucharest in a
capital city and then move further north
move probably to germany or poland
because in poland this is where there is
a significant ukrainian minority so the
ukrainian especially ukrainians
especially rather they want to make it
to poland actually where they have
relatives so it depends where you are
family but the priority of people who
are at the border here with romania
their priority is now just to get out of
the out of the country without having to
stay in line for hours as we have
witnessed yesterday here in chernivchi
nifty which is basically the last stop
before you exit this country
all right funny thank you dw's phony
fashion in western ukraine
you